Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Artificial neural networks are computer programs
that try to approximate what the human brain
does to solve problems like recognizing objects
in images. In this piece of work, the authors
analyze the properties of these neural networks
and try to unveil what exactly makes them
think that a paper towel is a paper towel,
and, building on this knowledge, try to fool
these programs.
Let's have a look at this example.
One can grab this input image, and this noise
pattern, and add these two images together
similarly as one would add two numbers together.
The operation yields the image you see here.
I think it's fair to say that the difference
is barely perceptible for the human eye. Not
so much for neural networks, because the input
image we started with is classified correctly
as a bus, and the image that you see on the
right is classified as an ostrich.
In simple terms, bus + noise equals an ostrich.
The two images look almost exactly the same,
but the neural networks see them quite differently.
We call these examples adversarial examples
because they are designed to fool these image
recognition programs.
In machine learning research, there are common
datasets to test different classification
techniques on, one of best known example is
the MNIST handwriting dataset. It is a basically
a bunch of images depicting handwritten numbers
that machine learning algorithms have to recognize.
Long ago, this used to be a difficult problem,
but nowadays, any half-decent algorithm can
guess the numbers correctly more than 99%
of the time after learning for just a few
seconds.
Now we'll see that these adversarial examples
are not created by chance: if we add a lot
of random noise to these images, they get
quite difficult to recognize. Let's engage
in modesty and say that I, myself, as a human
can recognize approximately half of them,
but only if I look closely and maybe even
squint. A neural network can guess this correctly
approximately 50% of the time as well, which
is a quite respectable result.
Therefore, adding random noise is not really
fooling the neural networks. However, if you
look at these adversarial examples in the
even columns, you see how carefully they are
crafted as they look very similar to the original
images, but the classification accuracy of
the neural network on these examples is 0%.
You heard it correctly. It gets it wrong basically all
the time.
The take home message is that carefully crafted
adversarial examples can be used to fool deep
neural network reliably. You can watch them
flounder on many hilarious examples to your
enjoyment. "My dear sir, the Queen wears a
shower cap you say? I beg your pardon?"
If you would like to support Two Minute Papers,
we are available on Patreon and offer cool
perks for our Fellow Scholars - for instance,
you can watch each episode around 24 hours
in advance, or even decide the topic of the
next episodes. How cool is that?! If you're
interested, just click on the box below on
the screen.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!